bonjour dhabi alors quelle est
l'ambiance actuellement eh bien écoutez
amira pour le moment les personnes
arrivent au compte-gouttes ici place de
la république pour ce rassemblement
statique afin de protester contre la
proposition de loi sécurité est globale
à l'initiative de plusieurs syndicats de
journalistes mais aussi du collectif
stop sécurité globale l'objectif est
clair le retrait pur et simple de ce
texte et notamment de l'article 24 qui
la pénalise la diffusion à d'image
malveillante des forces de l'ordre autre
rassemblement ici place de la république
ceux là des artistes et du monde de la
culture qui s'opposent à la fermeture à
d un lieu de culture a imposé par le
gouvernement
duo coronavirus du coup plusieurs scènes
vont se mettre en place ici
place de la république afin qu'il y ait
des prises de paroles d'artistes mais
aussi des concerts le tout pour que ça
se passe dans une ambiance festive bien
loin des images de violence qu'il ya pu
y avoir là durant les derniers
rassemblements contre le projet de loi
contre la proposition de loi
la sécurité a global à noter un
important dispositif de sécurité mis en
place ici tout autour de la place de la
république selon plusieurs sources au
moins 52 unités de forces mobiles ont
été déployés par le préfet didier
lallement des canons à eau également un
sont à disposition afin de dissuader
peut-être les derniers de dissuader les
manifestants qui est pour être s'avérer
un violent durant ce rassemblement en
tout cas tout a été mis en place pour
qu' il n'y ait pas de débordements comme
il ya pu y avoir auparavant lors de ces
rassemblements contre le propositions
contre la proposition de loi sécurité
globale merci david pour toutes ces
précisions sont retrouvés lors de nos
prochaines éditions